[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue est ce que les digues
ont sauté entre les républicains et le
rassemblement national on pose la
question à la suite des propos de
guillaume pelletier qui suscite beaucoup
de commentaires encore aujourd'hui pour
tenus sur figaro live dimanche du grand
jury rtl le figaro lci
on en débat ce soit avec vous et avec
comme chaque mardi alexis brézet bonsoir
alexis ponsot directeur des rédactions
du figaro le figaro qui revient dans les
prochaines heures
sur la question de l'automobile qui va
se retrouver interdite de nos villes
en tout cas pour le disait jean 2024 ce
qui fait quand même 50 % des voitures en
france qui n'auront plus le droit
d'aller dans les grandes villes d'ici
2024 tu peux absolument sûr que les gens
le sachent et quand ils le sont je suis
pas absolument sûr qu'ils en soient
emballées ça déjà commencé d'ailleurs
pour les véhicules qui sont été
construits avant 1990 est qu'ils n'ont
plus le droit d'aller notamment dans
paris et sa entre en vigueur
ces jours ci on va pas débattre de ça
mais on va débattre de ce qui se passe
chez république a avec béatrice giblin
également rédactrice en chef de
l'indispensable revue hérodote et aux
autres qui revient dans une très
intéressante livraison sur le maghreb et
le brésil sort aujourd'hui aux éditions
et dans dix jours en livrée en qui je
crois aussi tout à fait intéressant ça
on n'en doute pas un seul instant on
reviendra aussi sur un autre sur quelque
chose qu'on aborde dans le figaro mais
d'aujourd'hui cette fois-ci de nouveaux
déplacements des manuels macron en fin
de semaine dans le lot le président bat
il trop la campagne c'est la question
également qu'on pose sur twitter mais
d'abord la nouvelle querelle qui déchire
les républicains en cause donc les les
propos dimanche que vous avez pu
entendre sur le site du figaro dans le
grand jury rtl/le figaro/lci du numéro
deux du parti guillaume pelletier s'est
non seulement déclaré favorable au
rétablissement de la cour de sûreté en
matière de terrorisme mais aussi il a
déclaré ce qu'il a dit ce qu'il pensait
du maire droite dure de béziers robert
ménard s'est même
conviction échangé discuté travaillé
avec robert ménard ne me dérange en rien
j'estime que c'est un bon maire de
béziers je crois que les biterrois le
pense avec mes amis je considère que ces
personnalités qui se sont aujourd'hui
aux airs n ont pas compris que le rn
constituer une impasse mais c'est juste
qu'on fait cette étiquette alors ils
vendent du tout pas du tout c'est la
vision pour la france alors aussitôt
robert ménard on sait a salué dans un
tweet je cite la lucidité et le courage
l'audace de guillaume pelletier en
revanche les amis politiques de
guillaume pelletier ont c'est peu de le
dire un autre point de vue je vous
propose d'entendre michel barnier bruno
retailleau et également christian
estrosi
voilà je pense qu'il a fait une faute il
je pense qu'il en est conscient mais
nous allons nous expliquer avec lui mais
franchement je veux dire simplement chez
le moment de la responsabilité
collective et individuelle jeu je dis
que je ne me situe pas ni par rapport au
front national c'est-à-dire au
rassemblement national diam's yeux
marron je veux autre chose lorsqu'il y à
quatre semaines je demandais une
clarification
face à cette espèce de ni macro ni le
pen affirmé par certains où on sentait
que les digues étaient en train de
lâcher et ils ont refusé à ce moment-là
d'apporter cette clarification
il la mène aujourd'hui mais les digues
ont lâché vous venez de le rappeler donc
un certain nombre ont déjà franchi le
pas en direction du parti de madame le
pen d'être bien de l'entendre dans les
rets dans ses réactions tout le monde
voit dans les propos de paul tient à
glissement vers la droite de l air mais
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt une
tentative de rallier une partie de la
droite ce qu'on appelle la droite en les
murs ou bien une partie du r'n vers
l'est républicain guillaume pelletier
vient de lui même déjà de l'extrême
droite c'est le passage du front
national vert vers le lr donc qu'ils
soient séduits et qu'ils partagent un
certain nombre de valeurs et de prises
de positions proches du r'n ça n'a rien
de
très très étonnant quant à dire que les
digues lâche il est déjà arrivé qu'à des
règles du régional les digues et déjà
lâché en 95
elles ont lâché en languedoc-roussillon
elles ont lâché en paca elles ont lâché
quand elle a vu en quatre mois de vie
pardon génie 95 et 98 elles ont lâché en
rhône alpes
bon donc c'est pas la première fois dans
des situations régionales où on est très
menacée et où bon bah on fait les
alliances pour réussir à garder le
pouvoir
très très clairement je vous dis pas que
ce soit honorable et je vous dis pas que
ce soit forcément ce qu'il faut faire
mais enfin c'est pas la première fois et
c'est de nouveau dans une région comme
paca que les problèmes se repose
bon apparemment wauquiez a une position
plus que très net et je pense qu'il
n'est absolument pas dans la même
situation de menace de ne pas pouvoir se
faire réélire que ce qui peut arriver
sur paca et dans l'alliance de baume
muselier avec le la république en marche
il ya bien évidemment la montée là est
vraiment depuis très longtemps qui
s'affirme à chaque fois avec mariani qui
vient de son propre parti et qui lui a
basculé au rassemblement national
alliance qui l'a fait avec mme en marche
pour sauver la situation
alexis babeau jouer je vois que les
propos de pelletier sont extrêmement
maladroit par le moment auquel les
prononcent il est coutumier des propos
maladroits
c'est pas les premiers mais évidemment
avoir des élections où la droite est
plutôt bien parti où elle peut sortir
elle peut gagner beaucoup de régions et
sortir plus tôt vainqueur des régionales
les plus tôt en propositions allaient
commencer à faire des mamours offrons
rassemblant nationale ou crypto france
au mondial en ce moment c'est
tactiquement idiot et ça l'est d'autant
plus que venant de pelletier qui même à
des discours à géométrie variable qui
est des discours quasiment
mélenchonistes en matière économique
la question de la sincérité est en jeu
et fait que c'est très mal reçus y
compris dans son propre camp
une fois qu'on a dit ça je suis la
correctrice rien de tout ça n'est
nouveau c'est une vieille vieille
histoire à droite y est toujours et
depuis que le front national existe ya
toujours cette tension à l'inter de la
droite il faut pas oublier moi je me
souviens
mais même avant michel poniatowski du
temps de giscard et charles pasqua du
temps de chirac et charles millon il ya
toujours et cette tension là il ya
toujours eu des gens qui pour des
raisons électorales se sont alliés avec
avec le front national y compris
monsieur estrosi
car il faut pas oublier qu'en 88 dont
vous parlez christian estrosi était pour
l'alliance avec le front national
et c'est françois léotard qui bagarre
est férocement dans le rôle de l'east
rosie d'aujourd'hui pour empêcher cette
alliance contre nature
gaudin évidemment fabre tout ça et là il
ya pris à ceux qui disent pour des
raisons là pas alimentaire mais plutôt
plus politique le syndicat dire mais nos
électeurs sont partis au front social il
faut bien les faire revenir
donc on les fera revenir qu'en tenant un
discours énergique donc exceptions
toujours eu cette tension au sein de la
droite
entre une droite plutôt centriste moi
plutôt à droite et ceux qui veulent
s'allier
sinon salies du moins faire revenir les
électeurs c'est une vieille vieille
histoire
peut-être que le rn aujourd'hui est dans
une position beaucoup plus puissante
qu'il ne l'était en 95 qu'on est à un an
des présidentielles et que des victoires
vraiment aux régionales du r'n
crédibiliserait aux yeux d'un certain
nombre de ses électeurs la possibilité
qu'ils ont vraiment la digne l'hôtel
vent en poupe
il ya une vraie différence je suis pas
sûr que je sais que vous vous dites car
finalement le fonds social déjà été très
fort il a déjà été en position de
remporter des régions c'est à mon avis
la vraie différent il ya plus de
français c et 15 c c'est surtout
l'apparition dans marche jusqu'à présent
la tentation qui se la tension qui est
agité la droite c'était la tension vers
plus à droite qu elles l étaient tirés
dans un sens et chaque fois qu'elle
gagne des élections elles se regroupent
une fois qu'elle avait gagné ce qui est
nouveau et personne à droite n'a jamais
été tentée d'aller gouverner avec les
socialistes
structurellement dans les schémas de
pensée de la droite on les habille les
autres mais les uns et les autres
et voilà donc dont il y avait une
tension dans un seul sens ce qui est
nouveau depuis l'apparition du maquereau
nisme c'est que la tension à droite elle
exerce dans les deux sens et qu'au fond
ce qui affaiblit la droite aujourd'hui
c'est moins l'attention du fond du coeur
que la tension macron la droite a déjà
perdu quasiment un tiers de ses
représentants institutionnels enfin
r darmanin et quelques hauts et leur
fils et ce n'est pas tout à fait rien
donc la vraie de la vraie différence
aujourd'hui c'est à mon sens c'est celle
là où eux différence qui qui se
résorbera si jamais la droite
après tout tout est possible gagne
action présidentielle tout ce monde-là
se retrouvera derrière le le président
de droite qui serait élu et on
retrouvera les différentes composantes
plus personne ne voudra ni aller
fricoter avec malgré ni avec le front
national
en revanche ce qui est possible aussi si
la droite perde et la présidentielle or
la vulve son état d'affaiblissement et
vu l'état de cette double tension là on
peut tout à fait imaginer que la droite
en tout cas que la machine est leur
explose complètement
après ça voudrait pas dit que stream
défaite de la droite au sens des idées
de droite puisque au fond on aurait un
parti il y aurait une majorité et une
opposition alors qu'ils seraient la
majorité qui sera l'opposition entre un
centre droit macro nistos la république
1 et une droite extrême front national
au républicaine donc les idées de droite
aurait gagné mais le parti l air peut
absolument disparaître si elle est
repérée cette présidentielle justement
pardon je coupe parce que il ya un autre
notre déclaration qui m'a frappé dans le
figaro d'aujourd'hui justement dania
damien abad qui répondent à marion monde
dit à un moment
à propos de la fameuse doctrine du ni ni
qui était ni front républicain ni front
national
le ni ni d'un aplatissement de nos
valeurs un rendement de nos idéaux et un
renoncement à ce que nous sommes
donc quand on écoute daniel à battre
c'est que lui il est plutôt pour la fin
de cette doctrine là est donc entre par
exemple le rn et les républicains ils
votent pour eux mêmes ils votent pour
elle est vraiment bas il est fêté dans
la campagne de bruno le maire et si la
droite perd il rejoindra le maire et
macron c'est évident bon ben voilà c'est
exactement le chat si jamais la droite
gagne il se retrouvera derrière xavier
bertrand on parlera plus tout sera
oublié mon gendre
voilà c'est ça le la faire mais c'est
comment dire qui est des gens qui disent
je peins à la fois cette tension elle
est réelle entre églises demain si on
nous perdons nous allier avec macron
demain si nous perdons nous adhérons au
mondial c'est bien vrai mais ça n'a pas
de conséquence je crois jusqu'à la
présidentielle c'est au lendemain de la
présidentielle et législatives qu'on
comptera les mois le problème aussi se
lancer là l'absence de leader en ce
moment véritablement dans le parti a
l'air sur les nettement christian jacob
n'est pas un leader respecté par
l'ensemble de la de ces de ses troupes
pelletier quand même un numéro 2 s'est
pas non plus n'importe qui dans le parti
c'est à dire que s'il se permet de dire
ce genre de choses alors on peut dire
ben il a fait une faute comme le dit
barnier et il aurait pas dû et on va
laver notre linge sale en famille
mais ça ne suffit pas je crois à régler
le problème donc absence de leader parce
que si c'est xavier bertrand qui est
quand même le que le candidat c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a quitté l air
bon il va qu'on peut dire c'est pas
grave y reviendra
et comme ce sera le meilleur on votera
pour lui mais ça veut quand même dire
qu'à un moment donné et il n'a pas voulu
continuer à appartenir à ce parti on est
bien dans une situation quand même de
fragilité en plus c'est pas sûr que les
copains il lui laisse la place sans la
moindre des difficultés
bon donc on va rester dans un jeu
politicien qui va déplaire je crois à
une partie c'est vrai que c'est un gros
risque
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui au fond
c'est la machine et l'eire qui est en
quenouille oui parce que parce qu'elle
était vite elle s'est infligée semblent
de pure je vois quand on pense le debug
fillon copé wauquiez
ceux qui sont partis pécresse et
bertrand ceux qui sont partis chez mc
ren le maire d'alma
évidemment il reste plus grand monde
émanant diable n'avons pas grand-chose
bah oui il reste plus grand monde
le co ce qui est frappant c'est le
contraste entre cette machine qui est en
état de déliquescence et un espace
politique quitte à l'espace public réel
si on fait la somme des gens qui n'ont
pas envie de mariée de peine les gens
qui n'ont pas envie de milliers de mâcon
ça fait du monde
la question c'est est ce que quelqu'un à
droite venant des leurs ou d'ailleurs
peut incarner cet espace à occuper cet
espace là s'il arrive à l'occuper
potentiellement il ya la place de gagner
après faut encore arrivé à l'occuper et
c'est sûr c'est pas en s'appuyant sur la
machine à l'air qu'il n'a pas bien au
contraire elle est plutôt un frein il
est alors question subsidiaire par
rapport à ça est ce que les républicains
peuvent l'emporter aujourd'hui seuls
sans une ligne idéologique on n'arrive
pas à l'emporter à quel niveau bas
président commençait derrière l'oreille
pour déjeuner alexis disent ils peuvent
gagner beaucoup
ils en ont déjà pas mal suis pas sûr
qu'ils peuvent en sortir mais alors il
peut regarder ce qu'ils avaient sans eau
sans doute après je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il puisse ans en gagnant gagne et
forcément d'autres mais bon on va avoir
une très grande inconnue c'est
l'importance de l'abstention
voilà qui est à être sans doute très
importante
ça sera difficile maintenant je pense
que aux présidentielles on a vraiment
besoin de s'identifier c'est
l'incarnation de c'est le système qui
veut ça
on est à moins d'un an maintenant il
faudrait plus trop tarder ce qui
détermine qui va y aller quoi d'après
vous parliez d'un programme ou d'un
corps de valeurs et ses 600 800 m2 si
vous allez aujourd'hui 2 le 2
le maire jusqu'à pelletier en gros tout
le monde alors pelletier à la télévision
mettez de côté parce qu'il n'est même
pas libéré lundi que dimanche a en gros
la question de des libertés en matière
économique du conservatisme
en matière sociétale de du côté un peu à
pois une sur les questions d'immigration
et de sécurité et la naissance mis sur
la transmission en gros tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus les divergences
et elles portent sur la tactique sur les
alliances et thérapie mais pas le fond
culturel
en gros il est le même à peu prés pôles
il n'y a pas de fin en il est absurde de
téléphones mobiles compris sur le sujet
non le rôle de l'état ça peut être quand
même avec des des différences qui sont
peut-être plus que des nuances mais
incontestablement au luc dans la
victoire toujours eue il ya toujours eu
une droite en mai à nice une droite
attachée simuler le les gaullistes et
les udf
enfin bon c'est pas il n'y a pas eu
quand on nous raconte les deux trois ans
il ya bla bla bla c'est pas plus
aujourd'hui qu'hier déposition d'un
chirac qui disaient non moi le front
national c'est non et ça restera non et
ce serait les barrières qui en 90
faisait un programme sur fin du
regroupement familial tas de
l'immigration va de l'émulation
économique donc dans dans une alliance
partisane
si vous deviez là-dessus il avait un
mais pourquoi ans comme une sorte de
guide si vous voulez par rapport à un
électorat et il a enfin on pense ce
qu'on veut mais je pense que chirac
avait incarné après l affaire des
rénovateurs président et 98 mais pendant
longtemps il n'est pas du tout ces
lignes la fashion chirac s'était passé
au moment où il a fallu prendre une
position et dire à certain nombre de
choses il a su le faire et
en tout cas ça n'a jamais en trente n'a
jamais empêché de gouverner pendant
longtemps avec pasqua pendant longtemps
avec les udf y compris des unités plus à
droite que les refermant la question de
la de la diversité idéologique au sein
de la droite
elle est absolument résorbables comme
dans une violente quand on gagne en
revanche
et quand on perd il ya des tensions qui
quand on est affaibli comme aujourd'hui
peuvent mener jusqu'à l'explosion voir
comme les socialistes à la disparition
ou la semi disparition ce n'est pas
seulement la ligne mais aussi l'absence
de leadership sheller le parti se
décompose sous nos yeux nous dit
babineau les républicains ont de
nombreux points communs avec le fn mais
ils ont peur des critiques de la gauche
qui elle n'a pas peur de s'associer avec
des partis d'extrême gauche estime nous
dit françois micheline nous dit oui il
manque beaucoup de clarté et pour éviter
un duel entre le président et marine le
pen on peut s'attendre à tout il devrait
enfin assumé l'union des droites estime
en revanche général escape avec le rnc
ce que la grande majorité de leurs
électeurs attendent
est ce que c'est c'est vrai ça serve le
meurtre ne l'a pas ma fille pâtit
churchill il fallait le faire plus tôt
de l'union faut la faire quand on est
fort pas quand on est faible
s'il ya quinze ou vingt ans quand
edouard balladur qui était à peu près
soit digne avait un v10 bon allez on
fait entrer le front national on
retrouve deux ministères le front
national n'existe ray plus aujourd'hui
j'en suis absolument sûr bon ils l'ont
pas fait le faire aujourd'hui c'est
s'allier avec rien qui vous il qu'ils
aient dévorera évident donc s'opposer
aux propositions de clubs le font trop
bas vous surfiez les attentes et qu'elle
ne partage pas le point de vue d'alexis
la stratégie mitterrandienne
non pas que ce qui s'est passé sur le
sol sur le perron si ce qui s'est passé
en union soviétique
c'est à dire que le discrédit du
communisme à l'échelle internationale a
aussi joué et le pc était déjà en
position de reflux beaucoup plus bas
alors que mitterrand est donné sans
doute le coup de grâce je veux bien mais
le pc n'était pas du tout en position
dynamique et de force à ce moment là
c'est tout à fait différent dans le
cadre le pc avait été fort était en
déclin
le rn était au début d'une ascension
donc moi je ne
je ne suis pas sûr qu'un certain nombre
d'électeurs de droite aurait compris que
balladur donne deux ministères au front
national par tactique et je ne suis pas
sûr du tout et moi je mets quoi déjà on
ne peut pas re départ jamais refaire
l'histoire
ce que peut constater c'est le résultat
le résultat de l'histoire qui s'est
accomplie l'histoire qu'ils
accomplissaient ce que vous dites c'est
à dire le mur infranchissable
diabolisation le refus de toute alliance
est le résultat de sa objectif c'est que
depuis 84 le social ne fait qu'augmenter
d'élection en élection
sauf une parenthèse au moment de sarkozy
donc pas vraiment dire que si on n'avait
pas fait ça voilà je veux dire on ne
peut pas dire ce qui se serait passé si
on peut dire ce qui a été fait on peut
plus longtemps le refus de toute
alliance et le résultat c'est la montée
du front national n'a mais accepte mal à
c'est une hypothèse
ces démonstrations mais c'est une
corrélation avec une forte présomption
vous dites il ya corrélation pense qu'on
va pas vous à concilier les deux points
de vue sont intéressants et votre mac
effectivement sur sur l'alliance avec
les cobistes était intéressant c'est la
première fois je l'entendais et donc
merci de nous l'avons exprimée
dangereuse avec une force montante
qu'avec une force déclinant toute
évidence les républicains ont-ils de
clarté à propos de leur ligne politique
face à l om et le rn en tout cas vous
êtes assez sévères si vous répondez oui
à 90 % tout rond il sera jeudi dans le
plus beau village de france saint cirq
lapopie dans le lot se prépare à
recevoir
emmanuel macron le lendemain ce sera
martel c'est la suite d'une séquence
débuté en terrasse le 19 mai dernier
avec ensuite nevers également aux yeux
youtube avec mc fly et carlito on en a
parlé la semaine dernière le grand
entretien dans sa digue
on en a également parlé sans parler de
la tournée en afrique australe et en
afrique du sud alors emmanuel macron
fait-il trop campagne c'est la question
qu'on vous pose sur twitter sur sa votre
votre point de vue beatrice ask emmanuel
macron
ils ont son rôle ou bien ce qui ne
devrait pas moins se mettre en scène et
agir plus en un mot moins dans le
narratif plus dans l'actif écoutez je
pense l'un n'empêche pas l'autre d'abord
c'est bon c'est pas toujours 0 1 6 g
narratif j'ai pas actif bon je pense que
président c'est aussi s'activer
écoutez on sort quand même d'une période
de sévère difficile douloureuse
on commence à voir l'embellie le
président visiblement en profite bon
voilà va sur le terrain
ce sens s'en réjouissent ça donne ça
fitte donne sans doute le moral
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas pas
d'ailleurs non plus et que les français
sont en ce moment dans une période un
peu plus optimiste que ce qu'il est
d'habitude bon voilà donc est ce que il
devrait pas du tout aller sur le terrain
j'ai rarement vu des politiques quels
qu'ils soient et de quelques bords quand
c'est le moment de pouvoir un peu
profité d'une opportunité ne pas la
saisir
voilà donc en ce moment pour moi il
n'aime pas forcément trop pas en
campagne ça va pas durer toute façon
parce qu'après ça va être l'été plus
personne ne va être sera pensé à ça il
ya une fenêtre de tir
moi j'aimerais presque comme ça sur cale
en maintenant il ya aussi fini sujet ça
sur l'afrique australe bas il y avait
l'anniversaire du génocide du rwanda
donc tout le monde allait en parler il y
avait eu rapport du clair qu'ils avaient
été sortis
il y est elle est et je trouve qu'il a
fait un discours de mon point de vue de
grande qualité et c'était pas évident et
puis l'afrique australe sur l'afrique du
sud voilà bon mais maintenant ainsi est
il déjà en campagne bat un président
deux ans avant l'élection il est déjà
tous toujours en campagne
sauf s'il peut pas se représenter et
sachant qu'on est un an maintenant voilà
avant l'élection et avec l'afrique et
l'afrique australe endroit
on pourra dire que vous êtes rédactrice
en chef de la revue hérodote mais qu' on
vous avait déjà abordé toutes ces
questions avec beaucoup de qualité dans
votre vue alexis est ce que vous
partager le point de vue de béatrice est
également un des proches de qui
déclarent des manuels macron qui déclare
au figaro il est président de la
république dans un pays qui se rouvrent
l'immobilisme lui serait forcément
reproché au moment où il faut relancer
le pays
oui là il n'est pas vraiment question de
d'immobilisme puisse comparer fille
comme vous le disiez dans le registre de
l'action maintenant dans le registre de
la parole ce qui est savoureux c'est
quand on se souvient de ce qu'il disait
au moment de son élection il s'agissait
d'en finir avec la présidence hollande
cette présidence bavarde cette
présidence un peu qu'ils allaient comme
comme les choses vont et il s'agit de
revenir et de la verticalité une
attitude hiératique marc morel le leu
leu leu leu la pyramide du louvre le
command car l'économie de mots laids la
parole qui tombe tel le fil à plomb et
c'est bon par ailleurs fait ce que fait
tout le monde il parle il parle il parle
et et et ça lui réussit plutôt pas mal
donc je comprends que de son point de
vue ils se disent je vais continuer mais
je pense que ça va pas du tout s'arrêter
maintenant on est partis au fond il y a
eu le poste gilet jaune il avait déjà
commencé son tour de france a parlé
parlé parlé à faire par les gens mais la
très franchement c'est quand même au
détriment de l'action pendant ce temps
là on ne fait rien d'ailleurs je pense
pas qu'il puisse plus faire grand chose
maintenant
et là ça y est reparti dans un tour de
france donc parce que prendre quand on
nous dit on va aller à saint cirq
lapopie à martel prendre le pouls du
pays qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est un pur exercice de communication
ça n'a pas d'utilité particulière c'est
je me montre je parle c'est comme quand
le roi faisait autrefois le droit de
faisait la tour de la tournée du pays
et ça prenait de la moitié du règne et
d'aller toucher les écrouelles etc
enfin quand même il ya ce côté là le bon
le e ya pas lieu de ce scoop de se
scandaliser
la question me semble t'il politique
c'est est-ce que ça va suffire à ce que
vous irez entre entretenir ce mouvement
qu'on sent la 2de ben oui de
l'allégresse qui revient de plaisir ça y
est c'est fini et est donc est ce que ça
va suffire
est ce que il va réussir sur cette vague
let et finalement est ce que l'image qui
va rester c'est l'image de la fin du coc
vide et il a remis ses côtés lorsqu'elle
va durer comment on va atterrir sur le
plan du chômage c'est des questions qui
sont important est ce qu'on va connaître
peut-être une vague quand on voit
l'attitude des britanniques de nouveaux
sons un peu inquiet avec ce qui repart
assez rapidement avec le vario indien ou
je sais pas quoi
bon bref je sais c'est pas bon donc on
est on
c'est pour ça que je disais une fenêtre
de tir c'est à dire qu'on a un moment où
on enlève un peu des écrous si vous
voulez bon tout le monde est je viens de
traverser le boulevard haussmann vers
une ambiance la vue sur la question
est-ce qu'il peut tenir jusqu'au bout
sur cette vague et la licence apache qui
vaut bien ce qu'il doit faire autre
chose et ça m'ennuie le choix qu'il a
aujourd'hui les autres je pense que
c'est pas c'est pas du tout simple comme
question c'est ça va mieux ça va cogner
d'aller mieux vivre à la reprise
j'accompagne ça gentiment par deux
de la parole etc et l'un dans l'autre on
va aller jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle sans rien faire et après
tout ça peut marcher ou bien mais le
risque de ça c'est si ça s'arrête si la
vague tout à coup je me retrouve à la
raie au milieu de la mer et là je me
prends des bourrades des vagues qui
arrive donc c'est ou qui peuvent venir
de plein de sujets notamment les sujets
régaliens mais plein d'autres pleins
d'autres choses peuvent se passer que je
n'ai pas maîtrisé
ou bien je crée moi même le courant qui
va me porter contre lequel je hais les
éléments qu'on ait le vent contre lequel
je vais me battre
en décidant d'imposer un thème qui me
ressemblaient trop solide une réforme et
c'est la question qui va choisir
aujourd'hui est ce que est ce que par
exemple il va nous dire on fera la
réforme des retraites
1 enfin sa missive à 7,7 forme d'audace
à un an
franchement de l'élection on voit ce que
ça a coûté la réforme du travail à son
prédécesseur
en tout cas bruno le maire qui était ce
matin l'invitée du big bang des
entreprises a très clairement dit qu'il
était favorable à ce que cette réforme
dont la maison est probablement ce ne
soit pas ce ne soit pas le cas et ça
mais c'est vrai que nous mais qu'on le
dise encore qu'on veut il à faire ça
veut dire qu'on laisse entendre qu'on
veut encore bouger on n'a pas abandonné
c'est à dire que pour toute une partie
de l'électorat qui fait de ces retraites
quelque chose d'important ça veut dire
qu'on va la faire mais ça veut dire
qu'elle est toujours très présente la
danse à dire qu'on est dans la
communication et pas dans l'action ba
c'est le décès début de l'action parce
que moi ce que je me suis toujours
demandé c'est qu'est ce qu'on a fait
pendant deux ans parce que la retraite
delevoye s'en est occupé pendant deux
ans pour effectivement arriver à un
résultat qui était plus que dérisoire
voilà ce que je peux pas avoir vu que
les enseignants lé faire les frais de ce
qui serait évidemment plus la réforme
donc il était prévu comme on appelle sa
réforme de le voir non pas par amiens
prix que le système est systémique
quel personnage est bien compris on y
comprend tellement lourde à la france et
il faudra travailler deux ans de plus le
monde le sait c'est évident la question
c'est est ce qu'on le dit maintenant
enfin est ce qu on le fait maintenant
est ce qu'on le dit sans le faire être
mon ami ne le fait ni ne le dit on peut
dire aussi la retraite on la maintient à
60 ans mais vous ne l'avez pas taux
plein voilà c'est à dire que ce qu'il
faut il faut temps deux favoris
aujourd'hui si on veut retrouver une
moto in fact d'investissement parce que
j'étais collé de l'argent notamment pour
des investissements d'avenir
il n'ya pas d'autre moyen que de faire
travailler plus on travaille moins que
tout le monde en a déjà débattu mais
c'est pas de mettre les gens au chômage
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il le fasse mais
s'il ne fait pas le risque c'est celui
de de se retrouver en novembre décembre
pris dans des courants qui ne maîtrisera
absolument briner alors justement passé
avec alexis lité pour pouvoir c'est ça
qu'on sait pas pour reprendre pour
reprendre la thèse de la fenêtre de tir
de de béatrice justement pour reprendre
la tête de la fenêtre de tir de tout à
l'heure de ce que disait béatrice est ce
que justement il n'a pas raison à la
saisir parce qu'ils risquent d'avoir les
régionales avec des mauvais résultats et
on parle peut-être il ya d'autres thèmes
qui couve comme africa c'est ce que dit
bruno jeanbart aujourd'hui comme les
thèmes vous disiez régalien en
particulier l'insécurité en défense
régalien une enfance assez et il n'a
plus le temps
ni les moyens politiques de faire ce
qu'il faudrait pour satisfaire l'opinion
si tenté qui est un moyen de sur ces
sujets là de satisfaire une opinion vue
clan des 20 ans des 20 ans de politiques
notamment d'immigration incontrôlée
qu'il faudrait résoudre comme ça et qui
peut pas donc être là dessus et peut
être qu'en défense prendre l'initiative
là dessus ça me paraît très hasardeux
donc bon voilà dont la part se défendre
c'est pour ça que l'idée d'aller sur un
autre sujet ça lui éviterait de prendre
des coups sur ce sujet là ce sujet il ne
peut que prendre des coups et il en
prendrait dans le sens du jeu des deux
côtés
il était donc de kong hard le seul
discours sur la sécurité
on voit bien qu'il ya une forme de
surenchère et bien évidemment sur le
rassemblement national mais tout autant
se révélèrent et même la gauche
maintenant commence à prendre un peu non
non on en rajoute on en rajoute y
compris avec des propositions comme
pelletier qui sont absolument absolument
impossible à mettre en place
bon donc ça c'est un autre débat c'est
un meurtre et non mais s'ils le disent
s'il le dit c'est bien parce que les
sens que ce discours là il trouve un
écho au moins ils auraient ils
n'auraient pas vraiment pas un parangon
de de sécurité propose
la suspension des migrations oui mais la
suspension de légumes de l'immigration
je pense que non pas par le problème
c'est dans quelles conditions le
regroupement familial
michèle bernier il n'a pas dit qu'il
allait de l'arrêter l'accueil des
étudiants étrangers
michel barnier il n'a pas dit qu'il
allait l'arrêter et tout ça c'est aussi
de l'immigration et une grande partie de
l'immigration qui rentrent sur le
territoire est une immigration là on a
déjà débattu est une immigration légale
donc c'est bien gentil mais on arrête
les migrations je n'ai pas entendu de la
même façon ils avaient dit qu'ils
suspendaient leur regroupement familial
nous reste il dresse une minute mais oui
mais s'il propose quand même une
suspension c'est ce qu'il y'a pas
justement même chez des gens qui sont
chez les républicains qui n'étaient pas
les tenants d'une ligne dure sur ces
questions là justement un changement de
cap qui aussi les faits de la réalité
verdict regardez même aussi à gauche
mais romain c'est pas la peine d'aller
chercher à droite à gauche vous avez
aussi appris j'ai eu conscience que bon
à certains endroits et en quoi ça qu'on
voit mal macro marquer des points sur ce
thème là au mieux il peut ne pas trop en
perdre à skis ski ce qu'il faut c'est
que ça ne devienne pas un des thèmes
centraux de la campagne des
présidentielles pour lui peut-être la
nécessité d'inventer un autre est bon on
regardera ça dans les dents des semaines
et des jours les jours les semaines et
les mois à venir
on vous posait la question selon-vous
emmanuel macron fait-il trop campagne
pour sa réélection et vous répondez oui
à 67 % mais vous êtes quand même moins
plus indulgents que dans la question
précédente
françoise il se démène c'est sûr pour
faire oublier la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et il espère que les électeurs
seront sans mémoire
en quoi qu'on pense de ce que de ce que
dit françoise là où je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que dit françois sait
que or il est français le créditent plus
tôt de la gestion de la crise sanitaire
actuellement dans une personne dans la
popularité en tout cas aujourd'hui sa
popularité et plus de l'excellent plutôt
bonne et plutôt train de monter parce
qu'on sort de la crise à dire ça veut
pas dire que rétrospectivement les gens
pensent que la gestion a été bonne
ils disent on en sort c'est tant mieux
et la question est de savoir si est ce
que c'est cette dernière couche positive
qui s'imposera comme image globale on en
est sorti
finalement ils ont géré la sphère est ni
plus ni moins bien que les autres mais
bon bah ils étaient là ils nous ont
protégés ou bien est ce qu'on est en
train d'infuser mais ça on peut pas le
savoir
toute une série de critiques sur les
ratages en série auquel ont assisté les
masques les tests et vous n'avez pas
l'impression que dans les popularité
actuelle il est plutôt crédité bien sûr
qu'il est la question c'est comment la
percolation dans l'opinion va se faire
dans les mois qui viennent c'est là
c'est le moment
francis parcours où ça peut être de la
mémoire longue avec des relations avec
d'autres états pour finir c'était pas si
facile que ça à gérer parce que regarder
même taiwan aujourd'hui un compte dont
on a chanté les numériques se retrouvent
de devoir de nouveau resserré la vis et
ont conquis veut pas se faire vacciner
et ses médias puisque la nouvelle vague
a donc tous et tous nos calculs et
analyses politiques peu tout le monde et
vous micheline confirme il est trop tôt
pour se projeter à l'année prochaine
mais tous les politiques se préparent
pour la présidentielle effectivement
macro est bien plus populaire que les
derniers présidents et ce malgré les
crises se signale jean michel devant
l'effectif beaucoup beaucoup plus que
l'inde et davantage que sarkozy de sarko
merci beaucoup
on se retrouve dès demain alors pour la
deuxième journée du big bang des
entreprises qui sera consacré cette fois
ci à la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises
avec également énormément d'inviter au
tour de guillaume roquette et jacques
olivier martin et on se retrouve
également demain soir même heure même
endroit pour un nouveau numéro de points
de vue à très vite sur figaro
[Musique]